the two men have been named as Andrew
Bagshaw and Christopher Parry they're 28
and 48 they were in Ukraine they've been
here for a number of months doing
humanitarian work they left a place
called kramatosk in the donbass on
Friday morning and it's thought that
they headed to uh solidar it's about 80
kilometers away and they were reported
missing on Saturday evening now
Ukrainian police are extremely worried
for their safety because the fighting
has been most intense uh in and around
the solidar area it's very close to back
moot over the last week or two Russian
forces have launched a major offensive
and it's thought that they now control
most of that City I was in solidar a
couple of months ago and the fighting
then was extremely Fierce we could hear
the sound of explosions all around us as
artillery Jewels went on between the
ukrainians and the Russians there was
only one route into the town now the
Russians its thoughts are trying to to
control solid arches to the north of
back moots and if they if they manage to
seize it they can cut off communication
and supply routes to the Ukrainian
forces in back moots but because these
men haven't been heard from now for
several days there is great concern for
their safety